la coupe du monde de football débute
aujourd'hui en russie est le premier
match le pays organisateur la russie
donc jouera contre l'arabie saoudite ce
sera dans la matinée bonjour josé goron
moi je vous êtes footballeur ou golden
aion ancien joueur des matinaux nous
avons nous avions besoin de spécialistes
pour comprendre cette folie coupe du
monde
josé devant question toute simple est ce
que ce jeu est le plus populaire à
hautmont parce qu'il est très simple
très évident c'est aussi simple que cela
c'est un sport quand même planétaire
effectivement en effet que du monde
savait que si tous les quatre ans
malheureusement on aurait pu avoir
chaque année puisque c'est une grande
fête je pense que c'est rassemblement
planétaire et je pense que économique
moi aussi c'est une très bonne chose
pour pratiquement l'immédiat et pour le
pays organisateur qui a beaucoup dépensé
durant quatre ans 4,1 précédent et c'est
une ouverture aussi sur le marché de
l'emploi aussi pour certains certains
russes mais malheureusement a contrario
après la coupe du monde qu'est ce qu'il
y aura rien qu'il faudra profiter
pendant ce temps là
de cet événement suivre sur un mois
alors lorsqu'on est footballeur avec le
statut d'amateur com - vous aurez
bientôt 40 ans dont vous en avez vu
quelques campagnes de coupe du monde
oui lorsqu'on dit amateur comme vous en
at on vraiment cet événement oui on
attend vraiment parce qu'en fait c'est
pratiquement des sélections pratiquement
cessé le rassemblement des meilleurs
joueurs du monde et des meilleures
nations
donc forcément il a tenté et est grande
c'est sûr que par rapport à avancer
c'est peut être différent pourquoi parce
que médiatiquement ça les médias ont
pris énormément de place c'est à dire
qu'on peut voir des matchs de foot à la
télé donc forcément il n'y a pas la
grande foule qui avait par rapport aux
années précédentes
vos années coupes du monde précédentes
mais c'est sûr que c'est un événement
que tout le monde attend et même les
petits aussi les jeunes qui ne lui a
découvert alors raconté moussa josé
goron puisque vous êtes footballeur de
laguiole vous jouez les piles et les
premiers rôles dans le championnat de
martinique avec vos coéquipiers vous en
discutez de cet événement en fait des
paris d'entre vous ben oui ça dieu que
dans mon cas monnaie non il ya beaucoup
plus de bruit il ya donc moi je suis
français depuis le support graphique
sans supporters du société adobe maison
comme vous vous êtes supporters de
l'argentine et la chine et l'argentine
pourquoi d'argentine bain
l'argentine par rapport à noël mais si
déjà de base et puis maradona aussi en
l'année où ils ont gagné la coupe du
monde il y avait de tout dans cette
coupe du monde est à blâmer de la main
de dieu il y avait la victoire face à
l'allemagne ketting très bonne victoire
donc c'est pas parce que j'ai un petit
penchant pour l'argentine petite
confidence mort du supporteur enchanté à
cause de mario kempes en 1978 alors les
discussions sont vraiment acharnée vous
vous chambrer beaucoup oui on se chambre
beaucoup parce que bon moi j'ai pas
beaucoup et j'aime bien chambrer aussi
dense est vrai que bon les brises ils
ont davantage puisque ils ont déjà
pratiquement cinq coupes du monde livré
sur la 6ème parce qu'ils sont
pratiquement favori donc c'est vrai que
je n'ai peut-être pas davantage mais
avec mes deux équipes egypte meilleures
chances que ça fait de parler de ces
gourous vous dites je n'ai pas la
personnifier comme ça lorsqu'il s'agit
de parler d'une équipe de football
oui surtout d'une équipe de france parce
que moi je suis français avant tout et
je vois que c'est une équipe qui est
vraiment forte c'est là tu es bien
construite par le sélectionneur elle est
bien cohérente et ses cieux que ils ont
leur mot à dire maintenant par rapport à
mes coéquipiers qui sont pour le brésil
je pense que non ils n'ont pas choisi la
plus mauvaise équipe
il faut plus de ne pas choisir une
finale france argentine à y arriver
c'est ce qu'un avantage pour dean alors
josé goron lorsqu'on est footballeur
comme vous qu'est-ce qu'on attend cours
de cette coupe du monde à are bien
entendu les rivalités entre nations mais
en tant que footballeur vous vous
observez vous quand vous regardez le
match de point de vue tactique de point
de vue technique vous avez essayé de
guetter un geste que vous allez essayer
de reproduire sur les pelouses le geste
je pense que ça va pas évident moi je
suis je suis plus élargie quand je
regarde un match ça dès que c'est plus
tactique près des cailloux et voit un
match fermé mais bon tactiquement ça
peut être intéressant à regarder parce
que tu as vous avez plusieurs systèmes
il faudrait vraiment bien regarder
l'élaboration de l'équipe pas pour son
système de jeu donc c'est vrai que de
mon côté c'est plus niveau tactique que
je regarde de face à ce que
je puisse prendre en considération
certaines choses et puis l'inculquer
peut-être aux jeunes parce que les
éducateurs les footballeur peuvent
apprendre de tels événements ça permet
de d'orienter le jeu des années après
une coupe du monde
oui ça permet à oui puisque bon vous
avez des matches tous les jours
forcément si vous êtes un adepte du
football sceptre du bourget n'adapte des
des gestes techniques eux mêmes des
systèmes tactiques
je pense que les entraîneurs les
éducateurs pour un an considérant cela
et peuvent leur inculquer à leurs clubs
respectifs
donc ça c'est intéressant de
de regarder la coupe du monde mais les
matches de coupe du monde même pas sous
les jets steak messieurs l'élaboration
de l'équipe et le niveau de l'équipe
aussi une intensité de jeu aussi où êtes
vous êtes fasciné ou dégoûtés par les
sommes qui circulent sur son compte des
joueurs qui touchent des millions des
millions par saison de leur club
respectif
on va pas parler de messi de ronaldo
seulement il y en a d'autres vous
comprenez que on puisse être très
partagés lorsqu'on regarde de tels
événements partager c'est beaucoup dire
ça dès que c'est pas la faute des
joueurs d'avoir des salaires comme cela
je pense que c'est papa aussi à à
expansion du 10 sport mels général
football et c'est sûr que bon avec
l'arrivée des médias l'arrivée des
droits tv je pense que tout cela
augmente et financièrement ça qui permet
aussi au club de pouvoir payer les
joueurs de telles sommes donc forcément
personnellement bon je m'attendais pas à
ce que tout change mais je m'attendais à
ce qu'il faut du sultan moi je suis
footballeur bon je suis pas là pour
regarder qu'il touche 8 10 20 millions
moi je vois garder la boisson de
l'équipe l'élaboration du joueur la
qualité du joueur
et puis l'équipe
dans laquelle il joue mais lorsque messi
marque le but pour barcelone s'est pas
seulement le football club de barcelone
qui en profitent c'est toute la région
qui est à nuancer ce que disait
dernièrement un dirigeant dirigeants
politiques
on n'est pas saturé avec ce football
toute l'année fait des chaînes des
chaînes proposées même des championnats
du japon de la deuxième division grecque
du brésil on n'a quand vous êtes
passionné quand vous êtes passionné je
pense que vous n'êtes pas rassasiés si
on peut le dire de regarder des matchs à
la télé il faut pas regarder n'est pas
de calais matinale il savait qu'il faut
mieux les cibler aussi comment faire par
exemple russie arabie saoudite ce prix
de vente
oui mais par contre il s'est redit que
ça va être quand wade je pense que
l'audience sera énorme puisque c'est le
premier match il aurait été de la coupe
du monde il va y avoir toute une fête
avant ils voient l'avant-match l'après
match pendant le match donc je pense que
ce match là même si celui-ci arabie
saoudite je pense que c'est ce qu'à la
meilleure audience de la coupe du monde
j'ai l'impression avant les demi finales
et la finale
alors josé goron peu sur le joueur du
golden lion's avait également joué avec
le maillot de la sélection de martinique
vous avez rencontré certaines nations
qui participent aux éliminatoires de la
coupe du monde ça fait quelque chose
d'avoir le maillot de son pays
déjà c'est que ça fait quelque chose
déjà ce haut niveau de l'imsa dire que
quand vous avez des matches des matches
internationaux des matchs de la caraïbe
voir la digicel même de la gold cup je
vais en un petit peu plus loin puisque
je participe à la gold cup
je pense que vous entendez l'hymne
américain mais avant tout c'est l'hymne
français parce qu'il ya eu la
marseillaise on avait encore les états
unis et vous avez l'hymne américain
derrière c'est vrai qu au niveau émotion
360 et qu'il ya que vous êtes dans un
événement mondial quoi humanitaire est
donc en fait c'est vrai que le fait de
porter ce mail à vos potes un pays avec
vous donc il ya une très grosse
motivation aussi et puis il ya beaucoup
d'émotions en fait dans cette magie de
la coupe du monde
cette joie cette folie des supporters
c'est ça contribue à ce spectacle oui ça
rabaisse à dieu que c'est à dire que le
spectacle ça passe ça passe aussi de de
l'extérieur pensent que
le football a pris de l'ampleur par
rapport à tous ceux qui suivent le
football même les spectateurs mais les
téléspectateurs
je pense que c'est nous aussi qu'ils ont
qui font vivre font vivre le football
puisque on parle de l'audience on parle
de droits tv
je pense qu'avec les médias aussi donc
vous avez parlé de ça les deux jours je
pense que notion contribue aussi à
l'allégement oui est-ce qu'ils en ont
conscience et ce qu'ils ont toujours aux
sciences bonne question fédérer reposé
josé goron il ya quatre ans il ya eu
cette 7e coupe du monde au brésil
on a quand même l'impression que pour
2018 c'est pas la même ferveur
c'est parce que c'est trop loin c'est
moscou parce que c'est peut-être parce
que c'était au brésil sérieux que
c'était petit panda mecs en place si
vous parlez de haut niveau de la
martinique s'il n'y a pas une faveur je
pense que en martinique vous avez une
majorité de supporteurs du brésil donc
forcément y en a beaucoup qui ont été au
brésil en 2014 donc forcément peut-être
que vous n'est pas encore confirmée à 2
de cette union par rapport au fait que
ce soit en russie parce que ça reste un
événement c'est la coupe du monde alors
je sais comment doit question question
piège je pense que je sais que vous êtes
père de famille lorsque des parents ont
leurs enfants en centre de formation en
école de football au niveau de la
martinique et que ses enfants ont fait
une bêtise
est-ce que ses parents ont le droit de
dire à ces trois là tu n'as pas été
gentil je vais te priver de coupe du
monde c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
c'est très compliqué en fait ça dieu qu
il faut avoir un petit peu de recul
aussi je pense que si vous avez un gosse
qui clique est fan de football qui dans
une école de football comme vous dites
je pense que le priver d'une coupe du
monde ce qu'on vous dit de tout le monde
c'est du quinze du 14e au 15 juillet
dont vous pouvez pas le privé un mois
vous pouvez le punir mais bon à la
rigueur vont les proposer autre chose
que du sport pour un joug de jour même
pas pas tout la coupe du monde on va
rappeler que vous êtes un chien bull
puisque à partir de ce soir sur notre
antenne autour de pau l'eau il ira dans
cette émission qui va tous les soirs
refaire le match autour de polo il y
aura lauriane virassamy de journalistes
notre rédaction il y aura voulu raguel
germany patrice al alagui c'est la chine
autre technicien qui de l'autre côté de
la de la vitrine aujourd'hui c'est bien
au niveau martiniquais que que nous
commentions ses matches internationaux
c'était important parce que vous n'avez
pas si pas tout le monde qui regarde les
matchs sa nuque cette émission la pme
aussi des fins un débriefing des matchs
qui ont été joués
durand dian dian la journée donc il y en
a qui sont au niveau de la radio qui
coûte donc forcément c'est important
d'informer tout le monde c'est à dire
que les formations a pris une grande
place aussi parce que beaucoup de gens
sont à l'écouté de tout ce qui se passe
même autour du monde et en martinique
qui c'est vrai que bon vous pouvez vous
retrouver peut-être au plateau et puis
vous n'ai pas vu le match et par
prochain moussavou permet aussi de
savoir ce qui se passe au niveau du
match et on est là pour cent dans la
bonne humeur au rendez vous c'est 18h15
sur nos antennes tous les soirs merci
d'arrêter avec nos josé garcia si bonne
journée